il a eu 20 points de suture à la main à
cause de ce jeu sa moyenne générale a
baissé de 6 points à cause de ce jeu est
aujourd'hui neuf ans après il fait une
vidéo pour parler de ce jeu déjà je vous
expliquer ce que c'est depuis ce parce
que vous avez peut-être pas joué à neuf
dans votre vie dofus et mmorpg français
sorti en deux puis c'est ta mémoire pgp
ans est sorti en 2004
comme dans tout rpg tu commences le jeu
par une création de personnages et tu
vas choix parmi douze classes le but est
ensuite de péter la gueule un maximum de
mons et du combat au tour par tour de
manière à gagner de l'xp atteint le
niveau maximum qui est le niveau de sang
et pour pas être une énorme merde faudra
aussi que tu gères bien ton équipement
équipements que tu pour obtenir
directement contre les maux ou alors que
tu pourras fabriqués grâce aux
ressources que tueur a obtenu contre les
monstres
alors pourquoi je parle de dofus
maintenant parce que c'est le jeu de mon
enfance et ya pas longtemps ils ont
sorti un serveur mono compte je n'arrête
pas d'y jouer je passe ma vie à ça parce
que j'ai l'impression d'avoir douze
heures de nouveau j'ai même fait relève
sur ma chaîne twill sur dofus dans
lequel j'ai lutté une coiffe et cap
bouffe tout dans le même combat
autant vous dire que ma réaction était
digne de squeeze 2007 le plus de cette
vidéo c'est de raconter aux gens aux
anciens joueurs et aux gens qui n'ont
jamais joué au jeu des anecdotes
extrêmement cool
à propos du jeu me concernant j'ai trois
anecdotes à propos de ce jeu la première
vous la connaissez tous à l'époque dofus
à l'époque quand tu étais en combat dans
dofus et que tu fermes et relancer le
jeu n'avait forcément perdu le combat
bref vous savez ce qui s'est passé mon
frère a étampé cette force parce que
c'est à lui d'aller sur l'ordi gerra
j'ai tapé dans un quatre vingt points de
suture dans par bull deuxième anecdote
j'avais un meilleur ami à l'époque comme
tout le monde a un meilleur ami quand il
a 11 ans à qui se confier
lui parler de sa première amoureuse et
généralement ce meilleur ami tu lui
confie ton compte dofus pour qu'ils
emmènent ton perso avec le sien quand tu
ne peux pas jouer et un jour j'étais
chez ma grand mère je rentre avec ma
belle paire de terre-neuve à mes pieds
je lance dofus et que vois-je
je suis nul
équipement je ne comprends pas je
contacte alors mon meilleur ami et il
m'ignore totalement mathieu je me
souviens de cette anecdote pendant une
heure je ne comprends pas ce qui
m'arrive
enfin mon ami me mp en me disant c'était
une blague a à très grosse blague qui
m'a valu un traumatisme
il m'a alors rendu mon à brac askar qui
était un objet de mer derrière moi
j'étais content parce que j'étais un
doom et j'étais l'homme le plus heureux
du monde 3e anecdote un jour quelqu'un
vendait ce qu'on appelle une j'ai l'âme
huggel a alors contacté lui disant que
j'étais intéressé on a lancé les changes
il a mis là j'ai la mue et ce gros con
au lieu d'attendre que je mette des
kamas il a accepté immédiatement donc
j'ai accepté l'échangé alors reçu une g
la mue gratuitement et ce joueur n'a
rien reçu en retour j'ai alors fait ce
que tout le monde fait quand il vient
d'arnaqué quelqu'un j'ai changé de maps
et ce joueur m'envoyer des messages
encore et encore il était si triste
d'avoir perdu son âme il est si
précieuse
et j'ai été pris de remords et je lui ai
rendu son amulette gratuite merci à tous
je peux vous dire que c'est arrivé
quatre fois maximum dans l'histoire de
don pu sortir comme ça 4e anecdotes
pardon que j'ai oublié et c'est là m'a
valu une bonne leçon de ma maman dofus
est un jeu gratuit mais tu peux payer 5
euros par mois pour avoir accès à toutes
les zones donc quand on perçoit on
commence à avoir un certain niveau tu
vas être obligé de payer l'abonnement
pour pouvoir accéder aux zones qui vont
te permettre de continuer d'évoluer le
problème c'est qu'à l'époque on était
tous mineurs on n'avait pas de carte
bleue donc pour acheter de l'abonnement
il y avait deux solutions soit tu acheté
une pcf car je crois ça s'appelait dans
un tabac du coin toi tu prenais
téléphone de ta maman et eut appelé un
numéro payant et grâce aux codes qu'on
te donne et tu pouvais avoir une semaine
d'abonnement bien entendu tout le monde
faisait ça
j'avais fait rentrer code je ne savais
pas que c'était payant j'ai alors reçu
un coup de fil et j'ai compris que
pendant le mon avenir je n'allais plus
trop pouvoir jouer à dofus
il ya un truc dont j'aimerais qu'on se
souvienne tous et qu'on en parle un
petit peu les arnaques donc plus c'est
le seul jeu au monde où les joueurs
passent plus de temps à mettre au point
des arnaques qu'à jouer c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi des fameux code qui te
faisait avoir du hors forfait mais qui
permettait de gagner une semaine
d'abonnement et bain des joueurs
voulaient être les htc comme il mettait
alors le message
hachette claudio nos nouveaux tests
avant bien évidemment certains joueurs
s'amuser à faire semblant de vente des
codes mais il n'en demandait pas le mec
te donner les kamas mais toi tu lui
donnait pas le code qu'est ce que tu
faisais tu changes et de map
c'est l arnaque la plus répandue parce
qu'elle était vital pour les joueurs à
avoir l'abonnement c'était vital où tout
le monde essaie d'oublier un peu tout le
monde bref s'il joue il y avait vraiment
le moins de confiance entre les joueurs
mais de la planète au tout début de
dofus il n'avait pas le système des
changes tu pouvais pas échangé d'objets
avec des joueurs du coup les joueurs
avaient trouvé un moyen de s'échanger
des trucs c'est qu'ils allaient sur une
même map
ils se mettaient de part et d'autre de
la map et chacun posé par terre l'objet
qu'ils voulaient échanger à l'autre puis
les deux à aller chercher l'objet que
l'autre avait mis par terre c'était sans
compter sur la ruse de ces connards de
joueurs de dofus certaines personnes
malhonnêtes appelé un ami en renfort et
lui disait de se cacher dans un buisson
ou derrière un arbre sur la maaf voilà
et quand la mecque lâchent-ils objets
parterre ton pote le prenez
immédiatement
en vrai pour remédier à ce problème il y
avait un mode transparence dans dofus
qui permettait de voir à travers tous
les décors a notamment de voir si un
gros connard se cacher dans le but de
voler son objet mais les nouveaux
joueurs ils savaient pas ça donc ils
activaient palmade il sait même pas que
ça existait les mecs étaient tellement
prêt à tout pour être riche qui devenait
même mentalist y disait sur une place
publique je vous donne 10 % de vos
cammas lancé échanges
toi tu disais lemay qui donne 10 % nos
cammas mais il est adorable et tu étais
si pressé de gagner c'est 10 % de cas
passant plus pour ta bourse que tu
oublié de retirer la totalité des cabas
ce que tu avais mis dans les changes au
co réalité tu ressortait de cet échange
au lieu d'avoir 10% de kamaz en plus tu
avais 10 % de tkm as tout court qui
restaient dans l'inventaire ok pour vous
expliquer la règle suivante laissez-moi
vous faire un petit rappel dans dofus
tulle août des objets contre des
monstres et parmi ces objets se trouve
le gélat nos c'est un anneau qui donne
un point d'action c'est ouf un point
d'action dans dofus il est possible de
forgemagie les objets c'est à dire
d'améliorer leurs stats voire même de
leur créer de nouvelles statues
pouvaient donc forgé hommage et le gel
anneaux pour qu'en plus de te donner un
point d'action il te donne un point de
mouvement sauf que quand ça foire et le
gélat ne te donner plus rien ils
perdaient alors toute sa valeur mais
certaines personnes en chômage technique
pour quand même le vendre les mec disait
dans le canal commerce un canal que tout
doit venger la noce 50000 cammas c'est
un truc qui valait 1 million tout le
monde faisait il ya de l'argent à se
faire lundi dans tout le monde allez sur
la map du mec
[Musique]
milan s'est échangé dizaine en un an je
veux pas donner à mes copines comme ça
c'est pas cool je vais passer en mode
marchand et le premier qu'il l'achète
l'orage le mec passe en mode marcheurs
tu te dépêcher de cliquer sur jehanno et
de cliquer sur acheter pour vite la voir
et une fois dans son inventaire tut
apercevez qu'il ne donnait pas de points
d'action
[Musique]
mais quelle inventivité mais s'il ces
mecs là avaient mis leur intelligence au
service de la science n'est pas au
service des arnaques sur dofus mais mon
gars aujourd'hui on rouler dans des
voitures volantes sur une autre arnaque
c'était la toute première que j'ai vécu
c'est vraiment cela qui fait que d'un
coup et plus du tout neuf et tu vas
commencer à se méfier de tout le monde
n'est pas ton meilleur pote qui va voler
tout un bric à ce cas
c'était un matin où il pleuvait dehors
du coup j'étais sur dofus
bon après jetée sur dofus même comme des
soleils j'étais dans un truc comme ça je
sonnais lorsqu'un mais quand canal
commerce ami van cap bouftou 15000
cammas mp moi lui a alors envoyé un
message en lui disant mec je suis s'y
intéresser je le rejoins je lance
échanges et j'avais pas 15000 cammas
j'avais que 8000 cammas donc j'ai mis
huit mille j'ai mis des ressources en
lui disant bon mec les ressources tu
peux les vendre et au total y en aura
pour 15000 il m'a dit ok ça marche
inquiète
waouh il est gentil mais dans dofus et
comme dans tous les rpg ta part un
inventaire illimitée dès fois ton
inventaire est plein il faut un peu le
vide et pour pouvoir recevoir de
nouveaux objets et des nouvelles
ressources et cette personne là m'a dit
attends je peux pas accepter les
changements l'inventaire est plein
d'infos que je te donne deux trois trucs
alors il a mis dans les changes 2 3 6 9
truc j'étais content roi ou une capuche
ou pas cher plus des ressources c'est
vraiment un mec bien
mais tech qui sauf qu'en fait la cab
bouffe tous été retrouvés tout en bas de
l'échangé et j'ai pas eu le réflexe
d'aller voir en cliquant sur la flèche
en bas de les changes si elle était
encore là j'ai cliqué sur accepté il a
cliqué sur accepté j'ai souri devant
l'écran et en ouvrant mon inventaire
pour équiper la cab bouftou j'ai
découvert que elle n'était pas là il
l'avait retiré sans que je m'en
aperçoive
j'ai alors regardé son perso me disant
non il va quand même pas
[Musique]
l'acca bouftou plus tard j'espère que
cette vidéo vous aura rendu nostalgique
si vous êtes amenés anciens joueurs de
dofus que ça vous a donné envie de
plonger dans un jeu main nord pour dans
dix ans rejouer à ce jeu et sentir à
travers vous un feeling incroyable ça
m'a fait plaisir d'enfin vous raconter
tous ces trucs à propos de dofus
j'espère que ça vous aura fait qui fait
aussi et je vous dis à bientôt
vincent le mât rechange manger là nos
cinquante mille seulement le premier
qu'ils achètent
[Musique]